today's real exciting day because
vgk's come out in remembrance of one
october for appreciation for law
enforcement really gives a a morale bump
to a lot of the officers and the
civilian staff that just it's amazing to
have the support that sometimes we
forget about alvia for horrific reason
kind of cemented the bond between
the team and the community i don't think
that'll ever really be broken even
though one october was just a few years
ago it's so fresh in everyone's mind
it's amazing that vgk goes out of their
way to come out and support us each year
comes by and you're never going to
forget those people that lost their
lives or loved ones and
we just want to keep giving back on this
day i think one of the things that was
in the forefront of the team's mind was
to just to try to help a little bit you
know and i think the way you do that
kind of like what we're doing here today
is just give your time you know be with
people spend time with them show them
how you genuinely care about what
they're going through all the first
responders doctors nurses that
you know when such tragedies happen
they're running in and
not thinking twice and
going above and beyond every day uh
you know every day on the job so we just
want to thank them and recognize those
people and
do what we can to help